>> Tucker: THANKS SO MUCH
FOR THAT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: JIM COMEY AND
ADAM SCHIFF HAVE BEEN ALL
OVER TELEVISION DESPERATELY
TRYING TO ACT IN THEIR OWN
INTEREST AS ALWAYS.
TRYING TO DOWN PLAY THE IG
REPORT FROM LAST WEEK AND
HOW IT EXPOSED FBI LIES AND
IF PARTICULAR LIES TO A FISA
COURT THAT ALLOWED THEM TO
SPY ON AN AMERICAN CITIZEN,
CARTER PAGE.
ACCORDING TO JIM COMEY IT
WAS NOT A BIG DEAL AT ALL
COMPARED TO A LOT OF OTHER
MALFEASANCE CURRENTLY GOING
ON AT THE FBI.
NONE OF WHICH YOU WOULD
DESCRIBE IN ANY DETAIL.
THE FISA COURT APPEARS TO
DISAGREE.
TODAY IN A REBUKE, EVEN THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" CALLED,
QUOTE, EXTRAORDINARY, THE
FISA COURT ACCUSED THE FBI
OF REPIETIEDLY MISLOADING
THE COURT IN THE CARTER PAGE
CASE.
THE COURT GAVE THE FBI UNTIL
JANUARY 10TH TO PROPOSE
CHANGES TO ITS PROCEDURES TO
PREVENT FUTURE ABUSES.
PERHAPSY HEADACHES
FRRHAPSY HEADACHES
FRANAPSY HEADACHES
FRANCESY HEADACHES
FRANCEYY HEADACHES
FRANCEY HHEADACHES
FRANCEY HAKADACHES
FRANCEY HAKESACHES
FRANCEY HAKES IHES
FRANCEY HAKES ISES
FRANCEY HAKES IS A FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
WHEN THE COURT ITSELF
ATTACKS THE FBI FOR
SUBVERTING THE PROCESS, AT
THAT POINT THERE IS REALLY
NO DENYING WHAT HAPPENED.
IS THERE?
>> WELL, NO.
TUCKER.
IT COMPLETELY DESTROYS THE
DEMOCRATS' ARGUMENT THAT
THERE WAS ANYTHING PARTISAN
AT ALL IN THE COMPLAINT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP SUPPORTERS
AND THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
WERE MAKING EARLY ON ALL THE
WAY LAST YEAR.
EARLY LAST YEAR AND EVEN
BEFORE THAT TALKING ABOUT
THIS FISA WARRANT AGAINST
CARTER PAGE AND TALKING
ABOUT BEING SPIED UPON WHILE
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO MAKE
MUCH OF THE FACT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID HIS
WIRES WERE TAPPED.
IT LOOKS LIKE TRUMP TOWER
WASN'T ACTUALLY TAPPED.
CONFIDENTIAL HUMAN SERVICES
RUN BY THE FBI AGAINST THREE
DIFFERENT MEMBERS OF THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN INCLUDING ONE
AGAINST WHOM NOT A SINGLE
CRIMINAL ALLEGATION HAD BEEN
MADE.
NO ONE IS EVEN TALKING ABOUT
THAT.
BUT WHAT IS EXTRAORDINARY IS
JUDGE --
>> Tucker: MAY I ASK YOU TO
PAUSE RIGHT THERE?
HOW CAN YOU WIRETAP AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN WHO HASN'T
EVEN BEEN ACCUSED --
CREDIBLY ACCUSED BUT AT
COULD YOU SEED AT ALL OF A
CRIME.
HOW CAN THAT HAPPEN?
>> IT'S A MYSTERY TO ME,
TUCKER.
THEY SENT A CONFIDENTIAL
HUMAN SOURCE WITH A
RECORDING DEVICE OF SOME
KIND AGAINST A, QUOTE:  HIGH
LEVEL CAMPAIGN OFFICIAL THAT
WE STILL DON'T KNOW WHO IT
IS.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE ADMITTED THAT THERE WAS
NO CRIME ALLEGED.
>> Tucker: WHY THE HELL
DON'T WE KNOW WHO IT IS?
WHAT AN OUTRAGE IS THAT?
WHAT WOULD BE THE PRETEXT
FOR KEEPING THAT SECRET FROM
THE REST OF US?
>> I SUPPOSE PROTECT THEM
FROM BEING ACCUSED OF
SOMETHING THEY DIDN'T DO.
FOR FULL TRANSPARENCY WE
NEED TO KNOW WHO IT WAS SO
WE MIGHT KNOW WHO RECORDED
THEM.
>> Tucker: YOU KNOW, I
HONESTLY AT THIS POINT, YOU
FEEL LIKE WE NEED FULL
TRANSPARENCY TO ANYONE WHO
STANDS IN THE WAY OF IT
SHOULD BE CHARGED WITH A
FELONY AND PROSECUTED.
AT LEAST AS VIGOROUSLY AS
ROGER STONE HAS BEEN
PROSECUTED, RIGHT?
>> IT'S TRUE, TUCKER.
WHAT ROSEMARY COLLIER, WHAT
JUDGE COLLYER DID TODAY IN
FISA ORDER WAS SO
SIGNIFICANT AND SO
EXTRAORDINARY, SHE TOOK THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
CONCLUSION, SHE CALLED THE
FBI ON THE CARPET.
SHE LABELED WHAT THEY HAD
DONE WRONG AND A VIOLATION
OF THE COURT AND SAID THAT
THEY WERE NOT CREDIBLE IN
THEIR ALLEGATIONS AND THAT
THEY HAD TO, IN A VERY SHORT
ORDER, EXPLAIN TO THE COURT
WHAT THEY WERE GOING TO DO
TO MAKE SURE IT NEVER
HAPPENED AGAIN.
AND SIGNIFICANTLY, SHE ALSO
MENTIONED AN ORDER OF THE
FISA COURT THAT WAS
APPARENTLY PROMULGATED JUST
A WEEK OR SO AGO.
TOP SECRET.
SHE HAS ORDERED THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
ALLOW IT TO BE DECLASSIFIED
SO WE CAN SEE WHAT THE FISA
COURT WANTS.
>> Tucker: KEEP IN MIND
SO-CALLED LIBERALS DEFENDING
ALL THIS CRAP.
AUTHORITARIANS BACKED WITH